Speaker 1: All right, this you have to see
just another complete humiliation for the
former president, Donald Trump, who has been
hyping up or had been hyping up a press conference
for yesterday morning during which he was
going to make a major announcement.
Right wing news network Newsmax hyped it up.
Fox News talked about it a little bit, but
not nearly as much.
It leaked the press conference would be Trump
announcing that he is suing, filing a class
action lawsuit against Facebook, against Twitter,
against Google because they banned him.
And the event was so humiliating and so absurd
that Fox News even cut away from it while
Trump was answering questions.
Let's look at some clips, starting with the
big announcement from the former president.
Speaker 3: I'm filing as the lead class representative,
a major class action lawsuit against the big
tech giants, including Facebook, Google and
Twitter, as well as their CEOs Mark Zuckerberg,
Zuker, Sonder, Forté, Sundar Bouchet.
Speaker 1: That
is really, really something else there.
Speaker 3: And God bless the United States.
Speaker 1: Yeah, just a little more here
Speaker 3: and Jack Dorsey.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's the big announcement.
Trump is really, really mad that he's not
allowed to tweet.
And so he's suing everybody.
And of course, it's an embarrassment that
he's even doing this.
I mean, you know, everything, including even
like see how he has it sort of looks like
the presidential lectern, but it's not it's
kind of like a low rent copy of it.
But where it really gets embarrassing is the
guy just doesn't understand the First Amendment.
He just doesn't get it.
Speaker 3: The Founding Fathers inscribed
this right in the very First Amendment to
our Constitution because they knew that free
speech is essential to the prevention and
look to the prevention of hara hara.
Speaker 1: That's a H.R.H. if you're wondering
Speaker 3: and to the preservation of our
Speaker 1: republic.
This has nothing to do with the First Amendment.
There is just nothing here related to the
First Amendment.
And later, we're actually going to hear from
Alan Dershowitz, who wants to try to say this
is a First Amendment.
This has nothing to do with the First Amendment.
These are private companies with terms of
service.
And I don't want to get ahead of myself.
We'll wait for the we'll wait for the Dershowitz
thing somehow at this event about Trump suing
Facebook and Twitter, he ends up criticizing
Dr. Fauci.
Speaker 3: A lot of people ask me about Dr.
Fauci.
I like Dr. Fischer, actually get along with
him.
Great.
But they said, why didn't you fire me?
I said, no, he was good.
He'd recommend something.
I do the opposite.
And we always turned out to be around.
Speaker 1: So I don't even know how that came
up.
And then at this point, Fox News just cut
away.
If you tuned to Fox, you no longer saw this.
You instead saw a really important story where
Jason Chaffetz was talking about the origins
of covid.
OK, Trump was then asked about what happened
on January 6th, and the question was a good
one.
The framing was, well, you know, the reason
you ended up banned from these platforms was
because of what you did on January 6th, inciting
violence and all this different stuff.
So what is your reaction to the fact that
that's what you did?
Do you wish you had done that differently?
And somehow Trump ends up talking about antifa,
Speaker 3: just just to clarify, who should
be the arbiter of what's hate, what's offensive,
what should not be published, what goes beyond
free speech?
And because so much of this, your banning
has to do with how much made around January
6th.
Just to clarify further, what did you do to
stop the insurrection, as some people call
it?
Right.
And why were you not able to stop it?
So that whole event, unfortunate event just
went through Congress and it was
Speaker 1: an unfortunate event.
Guys, that's all right.
It just that that's that's all
Speaker 3: it was back and stand by.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 3: Unfortunate was issued and my name
wasn't even mentioned and I appreciate that.
I was surprised, frankly, because I would
have assumed that they would have come up
with their typically biased, at least on the
Democrat side statement.
The report came out, as you saw two weeks
ago.
My name wasn't even mentioned.
That was an unfortunate event.
I say, though, however, people are being treated
unbelievably, unfairly.
Speaker 1: So Trump is saying that the perpetrators
are being treated unfairly.
He's asked, what did you do to stop it?
Which is a, you know, indirectly reminding
us that he fomented it.
And he says it was unfortunate.
But the people who did the stuff are being
treated really unfairly.
They're the victims here.
Speaker 3: When you look at people in prison
and nothing happens to.
Antifa and they burned down cities and killed
people and no guns in the capital.
That's not true.
Burned except for the gun that shot Ashley
Babbette and nobody knows who that men were
if that were the opposite way.
Speaker 1: This is Trump, by the way, continuing
to try to dock's that officer.
Speaker 3: That man would be all over.
He would be the
Speaker 1: the guy has been cleared.
You know, it's funny because when they when
there's a situation where the left is saying,
hey, this officer acted inappropriately, they
immediately say, no, these these officers,
we have to defer to their judgment.
They're in positions of danger, etc.
Here there was an investigation and it determined
that the officer did not not act inappropriately
in shooting Ashleigh.
Babbette, which was tragic regardless.
But of course, she shouldn't have been there.
Now, all of a sudden, Trump wants the guy
dock's, if you can imagine,
Speaker 3: most well known and I believe I
can say, man, because I believe I know exactly
who it is.
But he would be the most well-known person
in this country, in the world.
But the person that shot Ashley Babic, boom,
right through the head, just boom.
There was no reason for that.
And why isn't that person being opened up
and why isn't that being open them up?
Speaker 1: Just just just take a scalpel to
them and open them up.
So Trump somehow ends up talking about, you
know, antifa and who knows what else.
And then this is sort of like Trump's new
line, which really applies to himself.
And I don't think that he really gets it.
Speaker 3: If you say it long enough, hard
enough, often enough, people will start to
believe it.
True.
That's what happened with Russia.
That's what happened with Ukraine.
That's what happened with.
Well, the worst is when they don't say it
like.
Yeah, the laptop from hell,
Speaker 1: that laptop from hell still really
bothering Trump.
And it is true if Trump repeats that he won
the election long enough and if the people
around him start to repeat it, people start
to believe it.
And that's exactly what what we're seeing
now.
Let's just briefly go back to the First Amendment
thing.
Here is Alan Dershowitz, who has bizarrely
become a big defender of Trump over the last
few years, saying this really is an important
First Amendment case.
Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Understanding is you have some
of the tobacco attorneys involved in that
class action suit involved in this case.
Seems like a strong case, but obviously nothing
is a slam dunk.
This is the most important First Amendment
case of the 21st century, and it's important
because it pits freedom of speech on the one
hand against the First Amendment.
On the other hand, that may sound paradoxical,
but remember, it's the high tech giants that
are banning freedom of speech.
They are censoring, but they're claiming the
right to do so under the First Amendment.
Speaker 1: So this is maybe the biggest distortion
I could imagine about this story.
OK, so Dershowitz wants to claim this is about
whose First Amendment speech is is trumps
the other.
Does Trump have a First Amendment right to
post to Twitter and Facebook and Google, which
are private companies?
Or do Facebook, Twitter and Google have a
right, not only under the First Amendment,
but also under business regulation law, which
Republicans are quick to defend when it's
other situations to enforce terms of service.
So it is not actually a First Amendment case.
That is the big lie with this lawsuit is that
this is really the First Amendment versus
free speech and censorship.
It's not it is not that this is quite simply
Republicans who say don't regulate business
now want the government to force Twitter.
To allow Trump to tweet, that is fundamentally
what this is about and it's outrageous, and
the entire event was humiliating.
It's going nowhere.
It's going absolutely nowhere.